ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TEAM CALAVERAS VIA
FOODORA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. AND
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. WE
PRAY TO ALMIGHTY GOD. TOUCH
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR LIVES WITH
YOUR HOLINESS. MAY YOUR DIVINE
WISDOM DIRECT ALL OF OUR
DELIBERATIONS. AND BE REVEALED
AND ALL PROCEEDINGS GUIDE US TO
PRESERVE PEACE REMOTE HAPPINESS
AND INCREASED COMPASSION FOR
OTHERS I MEAN. THANK YOU MA'AM
YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER LACKING. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THIS WONDERFUL
TRADITION. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE. ZERO ONE-
YEAH THERE'S A LITTLE. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. A
SIGNATURE MASSAGE SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY MAY FOURTH TWENTY THREE
ONE IS IN THE REST OF THE
ANNUAL COUNCIL DONALDSON THE
RIVER SEVEN JUST PRESIDING SHE
FORTY PROGRAM. BABY WOMAN
READING THIS RAMOS MOVES. AND
MR LACK SECOND. THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. WE
WENT TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
TIONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM AND. ONE
WOULD YOU PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS. ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
CARILLO JOINT JONES SAWYER.
RUBIO AND WOOD TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE HEALTH COMMITTEE
FROM ENROLLMENT AND RETURN THE
BILL TO THIS TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER.
S. B. THREE FOUR NINE AMBURG
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS EIGHTY
FOUR SB THREE FIFTEEN ROTH AT
THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAU. AND ITEMS EIGHTY SIX SB
THREE FIVE THREE ROTH AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RETURN
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB ONE FIVE
NINE BY THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
THE SENATE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY. I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU. GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION. DO YOU
MISTER FRAZIER IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER AT MY DESK MEMBERS.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A SPECIAL
DAY FOR ME. THIS IS THE DAY
THAT I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE. DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
RICHARD STEWART FOR HIS THIRTY
ONE YEARS OF. ACTIVE SERVICE IN
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
AS YOU KNOW I WAS THE CHAIRMAN
OF TRANSPORTATION FOR ALMOST
SIX YEARS AND HAD THE HONOR TO
WORK WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL.
MISTER STEWART. FOR THAT TIME.
YOU KNOW AS A STATE EMPLOYEE
AND THE HIGHWAY PATROL ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR SECURITY
AND OUR WELL BEING. YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT WE GET TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR SERVICES RECOGNIZING
ADMIRED RESPECTED. I WANT TO
THANK OUR MAJORITY LEADER FOR
HELPING ME MAKE THIS HAPPEN-
MISTER STEWART ALSO. IT'S GOT
SOME VERY. NICE PLANS IN HIS
RETIREMENT GOING TO EUROPE FOR
SIX WEEKS AFTERWARDS BUT A WELL
DESERVED VACATION AFTER ALL
THIS TIME OF GIVING HIMSELF TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC. SO I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF YOU HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. ENJOY HIS
CAREER. AND PAVE DUE RESPECT ON
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY-
BECAUSE AGAIN. THE HIGHWAY
PATROL IS THE LARGEST POLICE
FORCE IN CALIFORNIA. AND DOES
SO MUCH FOR US. THAT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DAY WAS RECOGNIZED AND
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION. AND
HOPEFULLY A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR MR STEWART. THEN AGAIN
TAKING THE HIGHWAY PATROL MR
STERN. ALL OF YOU. FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE ALL DO
TOGETHER THANK YOU. MISTER
COOPER AND MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER COOPER YEAH
ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
STEWART I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE- IT'S A LONG
TIME AGO THAT YOU THE
COMMISSIONER ACTUALLY
CLASSMATES. AND YOU RETIRED
BEFORE HER WHICH IS KIND OF
UNFAIR TO HER BUT I'M SURE THE
COMMISSION WILL DO FINE BUT
JUST OF THE LAST YEAR THAT'S
GOING ON FEES P. ISN'T A GREAT
JOB HERE TO CAPITOL IN PLANO
HERE ENOUGH BUT PROTECTING US
IN THE FUTURE- THE CAPITAL'S
BEEN SAY FANS WE APPRECIATE
THAT FOR ALL YOU DO. WELL IT'S
A LONG CAREER WELL DESERVED I
MEAN. YOU CAN'T GET MUCH HIGHER
THAN BESIDES BEING THE
COMMISSIONER SO ONE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA
ALL YOU DONE AND ENJOY
RETIREMENT- IT'S WELL DESERVED.
THANK YOU SIR. MISTER MR LACK
YOUR- YEAH JUST WANNA RETIRED
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROLMEN TO
A FUTURE- RETIRED CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN I KNEW YOU
WHEN WE WERE BOTH A LOT YOUNGER
AND- I'M VERY VERY PROUD OF
YOUR SERVICE AND YOU YOU DID
ABOUT AS GOOD AS HI PATROLLING
CAN ACTUALLY DO YOUR NUMBER
TWO. SO CONGRATULATIONS AND GO
ENJOY SIR. HEY MR COOLEY MR
COOLEY OR RECOGNIZE. WELL I
WANNA ALSO JUST SPEAK UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE WORK OF YOUR AGENCY AND
SECURING OUR CAPITAL ON I GO
BACK TO THE DAYS OF GLENN CRAIG
IS COMMISSIONER HE WAS MY FIRST
COMMISSIONER I KNEW. BUT I WANT
TO TELL EVERYONE HERE THAT FOR
MORE THAN FOUR YEARS THE CHP
AND WITH OUR SERGEANTS HAVE A
WORKING STEADILY LOOKING AT THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE THE PROSPECT OF
REBUILDING IT. LOOKING AT THE
NEEDS IN THE SECURITIES FOR
MEMBERS PUBLIC ALL THE REMARK
RECEIVED UNFOLDS HERE TO KEEP
IT SAFE AND SECURE WITHOUT A
FORTRESS FEEL THERE IS JUST AN
ASTONISHING AMOUNT OF STEADY
LABOR. THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION
TOOK THE LEAD ON AGAIN SINCE
THE SPRING OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
FOR MORE THAN FOUR YEARS NOW
AND EVEN IN THE WAKE OF.
JANUARY SIX. OF THAT SIMPLY
PROVIDED A FURTHER IMPETUS TO
JUST REVIEW ALL THE WORK THAT
FOR YEARS. TO ESTABLISH A
SECURE PLAN FOR OUR MOST
PRECIOUS PUBLIC BUILDING BUT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR LONG
SERVICE. AND HOW PRECIOUS WE
ALL NOW UNDERSTAND IT IN LIGHT
OF THE EVENTS OF. THIS YEAR
THAT CAPTURE CAREER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO. BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
COOKERY ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE MINUTES
IN A BILL FOR NINETY EIGHT FIVE
TWO OVER THE MINISTRY THIRTY
SIX OF THEM EVERY SIXTEEN WITH
A MINISTRY TWENTY WITH THE
MINISTRY TWENTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS THREE FORTY THREE WITH
A MEMBERS FIVE THIRTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE FREE WITH A
MEMBERS FOR SIXTY ONE FIVE OR
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBERS FOR TWENTY WITH MEMBERS
FIVE THIRTY FIVE OF ITS SIX SIX
FOR THE MEMBERS SEVEN FORTY
NINE OF THE MEMBERS. TO
NINETEEN TO FIFTY EIGHT TO
NINETY TWO THREE THIRTY THREE
FOR ELEVEN FOR EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY FOUR SEVEN SEVEN NINE
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT
SEVENTEEN EIGHT TWENTY ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE TO SEVENTY FOUR TO
NINETY FOUR FOUR TEN SIXTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX OF THE MOMENT SEVEN
NINETY TWO WITH A MINUTES FIVE
TWENTY THREE WITH A MINUTES.
AND SENATE BILL NINETY SEVEN
WITH A MENACE. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
AND THIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO
TAKE UP AB ONE SIX ONE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. HEY MISTER
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE. WE WERE
HOLDING HANDS CONSENT ASTRAL
CALL VOTE MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MISTER RAMOS MOVES
AND MISTER CHOW SECONDS ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE. IS RACES ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MR FLOOR IT IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. HIS RANTS
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. IN
MISTER FLORA AND NO THIS IS
PROCEDURAL MEMBERS. ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ROLE I FIFTY SIX NO SIXTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. MISTER CHANG IF YOU'RE
READY TO TAKE UP. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SIXTY ONE THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB. ONE SIX
ONE. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET
BILL. MR CAME A OPEN I THINK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE SIXTY
ONE MAKE SOME CLARIFICATIONS TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. FIRST TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OF TOTAL FUNDS THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FOREST
RESILIENCY THAT'S AVAILABLE
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. VOIGTS
COUNTIES TWENTY EIGHT POINT
FOUR MILLION FOR THE RECALL
ELECTION IS ESTIMATED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. IT ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL LNGUAGE
FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN CONSERVANCY
FUNDING. TO CLARIFY THE USE IN
A COMPASS PERMITS FOR THE
FUNDS. AND THEN LASTLY CRUX OF
BRIDIE OF DRAFTING ERRORS THAT
WERE MADE IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT I WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. ON AB ONE SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR CHANG MR FONG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. A MEMBERS THIS
IS OUR THIRD BUDGET BILL IN
FOUR WEEKS. IT APPEARS WE ARE
RELIVING A SCENE AND GROUNDHOG
DAY EACH DAY WE LEARN OF A NEW
BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH DETAILS
STILL TO BE DETERMINED AND A
RUSH TIME LINE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING. AND THEN WE
REPEAT THIS DYNAMIC OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. WELL MAYBE THE
BETTER ANALOGY IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS BUDGETING LIKE
EVERY IPHONE UPDATE USERS
UPDATE THEIR PHONES ONLY TO SEE
THAT ANOTHER UPDATE NEED TO
TAKE PLACE. RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON
BUDGET THREE POINT NOW. WE ARE
HERE BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR IS
FINALLY ACKNOWLEDGING. THAT HIS
PREVIOUS BUDGETS WERE NOT
ENOUGH ESPECIALLY A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE DEMANDED. COMMUNITIES ARE
BEGGING. MORE LIKE PLEADING TO
GET MORE DONE WHEN IT COMES TO
PREVENTING WILDFIRES. CAL FIRE
IS DOING ALL THEY CAN. BUT THEY
NEED MORE RESOURCES AND HELP
AND ESPECIALLY MORE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE READY. AND
WILLING TO HELP IN THE FIGHT TO
PREVENT MORE FIRES. WE NEED A
SENSE OF URGENCY. WE NEED TO
ACT NOW AND WE NEED TO COMMIT
MORE FUNDING ON A CONTINUOUS
AND ONGOING BASIS FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. AND WE NEED TO
STREAMLINE THE APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR THESE CRITICAL WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS. ENABLING AND
MOBILIZING ARE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL NONPROFITS TO DO
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. HAS TO
BE A TOP PRIORITY AS WE FACE AN
EXTREME DROUGHT IN ALREADY HOT
SUMMER. AFTER THIS FUNDING IS
APPROVED WE NEED TO MOVE
QUICKLY. THREE YEARS AGO I
STOOD WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
PARADISE AT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
I ALONG WITH A BIPARTISAN GROUP
OF MEMBERS HEARD A HEART
WRENCHING STORIES FROM FAMILIES
OF THEIR ESCAPE FROM THE CAMP
FIRE THAT TOOK EIGHTY FIVE
LIVES. AND DISPLACED NEARLY AN
ENTIRE TOWN. THAT SCHOOL WAS
SAVED BECAUSE A FORCE
MANAGEMENT THAT WAS DONE WELL
BUILDINGS IN HOMES ACROSS THE
WAY WERE DESTROYED. MANY OF US
HAVE OUR OWN MEMORIES
WITNESSING THE DEVASTATION FROM
KESARI WILDFIRES IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES WE KNOW WHAT MUST
BE DONE AND NOW WE MUST ACT
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY. ACCESS
TO THESE RESOURCES VERY. THANK
YOU MR FONG MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS- I DO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS TRAILER BILL TODAY- BUT
WE ARE FOOLING OURSELVES. IF WE
THINK THAT THIS TAKES CARE OF
THE PROBLEM- ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION NOW I'VE- SPOKEN ON
THIS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. ABOUT
THE NEED TO HAVE SUSTAINED
FUNDING EVERY YEAR IN THIS
BUDGET TO DO THE WORK THAT WE
ALL NEEDS THAT WE ALL KNOW
NEEDS TO BE DONE. TO TRULY GET
ON TOP OF THIS PROBLEM TO HELP
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
PROTECT OUR AIR. AND TO
PROTECT. THE CARBON EMISSIONS
GOALS THAT WE HAVE SET. FOR
THIS STATE. WE NEED TO BE DOING
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A
YEAR. OF PREVENTION TREATMENT.
RECENT ARTICLES REVEALED THAT
WE DID A LEVIN THOUSAND. A.
KERR'S UNDER A STREAMLINED
SEQUEL PROCESS. THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY NOT GETTING THE JOB
DONE. NOW THIS TRAILER BILL
AUTHORIZES ANOTHER FIVE
HUNDRED. MILLION DOLLARS THE
GENERAL FUND. AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT THE PROBLEM IS. IT
DOESN'T APPROPRIATE THAT MONEY.
IT DOESN'T GET IT OUT TO THOSE
WHO NEED TO DO THE WORK. IT
SAYS AND I QUOTE UPON THE ORDER
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
UP TO AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION A GENERAL FUND
MONIES MAY BE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION THAT'S
THE SAME. ADMINISTRATION THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THEY TOLD US
LAST WEEK THERE ARE CAPACITY
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD. THE
SAME ADMINISTRATION THAT HASN'T
GOTTEN THE JOB DONE ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION ALREADY DID ONLY DID
ELEVEN THOUSAND WHEN THEY SAID
THEY DID NINETY THOUSAND.
THAT'S THE SAME ADMINISTRATION.
THEY CONTINUES TO THWART THE
WILL OF THIS LEGISLATURE AND DO
ITS OWN THING AND WE'RE GOING
TO PUT ALL THE POWER IN THE
ABILITY USE THIS MONEY ONCE
AGAIN IN THE GOVERNOR'S HANDS
INSTEAD OF US DIRECTING THAT
THAT MONEY BE SPENT ON PROJECTS
THAT WE ALL KNOW. NEED TO BE
DONE AND IF THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH CAPACITY THEY GET THE
MONEY OUT TO THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS INTO THE NON PROFITS
AND LET'S WORK WITH PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO GET TO THAT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE MARK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. LET'S
TREAT THIS WITH THE URGENCY.
THAT WE ALL KNOW IT DESERVES.
AND LET'S REMOVE THE BARRIERS
LIKE SYKORA. THAT STOP PROJECTS
FROM MOVING FORWARD LIKE BERRY
CREEK THAT BURNED LAST YEAR
READY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
FUNDING BUT IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS
EQUAL PROCESS BEFORE THEY COULD
DO ANYTHING. VERY CREEK IS NO
LONGER THERE. THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO STOP. I'M NOT GONNA GO
THROUGH ANOTHER YEAR. AND WE
NEED TO TREAT THIS WITH THE
REAL URGENCY THAT THE SITUATION
DEMANDS. AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO PUSH ON THIS. UNTIL WE GET
THERE THANK YOU. THANKS
GALLAGHER I SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM IS HURTING YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. SECOND
SPEAKER. I KNOW THE TOPIC OF
WILDFIRES ESPECIALLY AS WINTER
WILDFIRE SEASON IS ONE THAT WE
ALL SHARE A SENSE OF URGENCY ON.
I WANT TO REMIND THIS BODY THAT
AGAIN WILDFIRES ARE ONE OF THE
MOST NATURAL OCCURRENCES.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY.
WALFORD'S UNNATURAL. OUR
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN WE NOW HAVE
SPREAD TO LIVING IN ALL PARTS
OF THE STATE. WHERE WE ARE NEXT
TO FORESTS AND TREES IN THIS
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS
OF WILDFIRE PREVENTION. HAS
BEEN BECAUSE OF YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS OF NEGLECT. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WAS CREATED
OVERNIGHT AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN SOLVE
OVERNIGHT. I KNOW THAT WE AS A
BODY COMPLETELY FEEL THE SENSE
OF URGENCY. THIS CODIFIES THE
MONEY FOR POTENTIAL PREPARATION
AND THE REASON THAT WE HAVEN'T.
DELINEATE EXACTLY HOW MUCH%
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING IS BECAUSE
WE'RE DOING EXACTLY WHAT. OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM NICKEL SAID
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO IDENTIFY EXACTLY WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING WE'RE NOT
ALLOWING. THE ADMINISTRATION
JUST TO SPEND THE MONEY ON
WHATEVER PROJECT THEY WANT WE
ARE ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM. TO ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATION REFLECTS THIS
BODY REFLECTS THE SENATE REALLY
REFLECTS THE CONSTITUENTS UP
AND DOWN. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR AB
ONE SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
MICHELLE. AND WITH THAT CLICK
LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE VOTE.
CLARK WELL
THE- CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN. MS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE AND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE OF AB ONE THIRTY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE INSTEAD.
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS. MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE ARE WITHHOLDING
EVIDENCE AND ASTRAL CALLED
OKAY. MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT
MS REYES MOVES MISTER CHOW
SECONDS ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS ANOTHER
PROCEDURAL VOTE. CARPOOL UP IN
THE WRONG. RACES ASKING FOR AND
I VOTER MISTER FLORES ASKING
FOR NO VOTE. MS RACES ASKING
FOR AYE VOTE AND MR FLORA AND
NO. THE CLERK WILL. BECAUSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY SIX NO
SIXTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS OF THAT REFERENCE THE
FILE. ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE THIRTY
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY BY THE- MEDIA BUDGET AND
ALKYLATING TO EDUCATE FINANCING
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF COURSE
TAKE A COMMUNITY PRIVILEGE OF
THE BUDGET MISTER CAN YOU MAKE
IT OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ONE THIRTY WHICH IS OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL. THIS LAST YEAR
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE HAS
BEEN CHALLENGED LIKE NO OTHER
TIME BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
TEACHERS STRUGGLED TO TEACH
CLASSES VIA ZOOM WE STRUGGLE TO
KEEP OUR STUDENTS ENGAGE
ESPECIALLY ARE VERY YOUNG
STUDENTS WE WORKED VERY HARD AS
A BODY TO GET OUR SCHOOLS TO
COME BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO WE HAD A
VERY- BIG DEBATE ON WHAT WE
COULD DO TO BRING OUR STUDENTS
BACK TO BRING OUR TEACHERS BACK
TO BRING OUR STAFF BACK. TODAY
BECAUSE OF OUR RECORD SURPLUS.
WE ARE STANDING TO PRESENT
RECORD FUNDING. TO OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. THIS IS A FUNDING
PROPOSAL TO SPEND OVER TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A RECORD
AMOUNT PER STUDENT. NINETY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS ON PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING. IT WITHIN
THAT WE HAVE NUMEROUS PROPOSALS
ARE OF WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS. OUR
COLLEAGUE WHO CHAIRS UP TO AND
FROM SACRAMENTO HAS BEEN
FIGHTING FOR UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. FOR
THE LAST DECADE. AND TODAY IS
FINALLY THE DAY THAT WE ARE
ANNOUNCING THAT NO MORE ARE WE
GOING TO ONLY ALLOW 25% OF
STUDENTS. TO HAVE UNIVERSAL T.
K. 25% OF FOUR YEAR OLDS HAVE A
TICKET NOW WE ARE MOVING TOWARD
UNIVERSAL T. K. FOR EVERY
SINGLE FOUR YEAR OLD. IN THIS
STATE LONG OVERDUE. WE ARE
PUTTING FOR TO PULL TO RUN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. SCHOOLS THAT
ARE REALLY. ETHNOLOGY WHAT THE
OUR SCHOOLS NOW ARE NO LONGER
TO THE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE GET
EDUCATION. SCHOOLS ARE HELD FOR
THE COMMUNITY. THERE WERE THE
COMMUNITY GOES BEFORE SCHOOL
THEY GO AFTER SCHOOL TO OUR
CHILDREN GET FED. IT'S WERE
CHILDREN GOOD VISION-
APPOINTMENTS WITH THE GET
DENTAL APPOINTMENTS WHERE THEY
GET HEALTH CHECKS. FOR SCHOOLS
ARE A MICROCOSM OF OUR
COMMUNITY IN THIS THREE BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL ONE TIME
PROPOSAL. LAUNCHES ARE
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN. IS TO GIVE THEM THE
RESOURCES TO BE THE COMMUNITY
HUBS BUT TO HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR THE
COMMUNITY SO MANY. OF THESE
RESOURCES ARE STRETCHED BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF FUNDING. WE'RE
ALSO DOING EXPANDABILITY. WE
SAW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU CAN'T
HAVE BEFORE SCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL
CHILDCARE. SO MANY FAMILIES
DIDN'T GO BACK WHEN SCHOOLS
REOPEN BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
AFTER SCHOOL. SO WE ARE DOING A
BILLION DOLLARS OF ONGOING PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY. TO BULK UP
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM FOR SO
MANY WORKING FAMILIES LIKE MINE
YOU DON'T HAVE AFTER SCHOOL
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES HAVE TO
STRUGGLE. BETWEEN THE CHOICE
BETWEEN WORKING OR ACTUALLY
WATCHING THEIR CHILDREN AFTER
SCHOOL. WITH ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF ONGOING PROP NINETY
EIGHT AS WELL SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
ONE TIME TO SERVE HALF OF OUR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN THE
STATE. IT'S THREE HUNDRED
NINETY SIX MILLION FOR ONGOING
POP NINETY A SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING. TO INCREASE THE
STATEWIDE BASE RATE FOR OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION FORMULA. WE
ALSO DOUBLE THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT ACCESS TO CAREER AND
COLLEGE PREP COURSEWORK AND
TRAINING. AND LASTLY WE LAUNCH
OUR FIRST UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS PROGRAM. WE HAVE WAY TOO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
GOING HUNGRY EVERY DAY. AND
QUITE OFTEN IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE MEAL THAT THEY GOT AT
SCHOOL THEY WOULD NECESSARILY
GET A BILL AT ALL. SO THIS WILL
REIMBURSE OUR STATE IS A STATE
INCREASE IN STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENTS BY FIFTY FOUR
MILLION. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IS SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONGOING. IMPROPER
NINETY BEGINNING AT TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO COVER THE COSTS
OF OFFERING BREAKFAST AND LUNCH
FOR ALL STUDENTS. THIS BILL IS
A TRULY TRANSFORMATIONAL BUDGET
FOR OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE
SYSTEM. REALLY PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES FOR WHAT OUR SYSTEM
HAS ALREADY BECOME. A COMMUNITY
HUB WHERE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
RELY ON FOOD ON HEALTHCARE
SOCIAL SERVICES ALL IN AFRICA
SO THAT THEY CAN GO TO WORK.
WITH THAT I'M VERY PROUD TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB ONE THIRTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
FOR STAYING MISTER FONG YOUR
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WHILE THIS BILL DOES
ADDRESS THE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
DEFERRALS THAT SCHOOLDISTRICTS
ARE FACING. I'M AFRAID THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT IN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FRUSTRATION FOR OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT MOVES AWAY
FROM THE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE
OF LOCAL CONTROL. AND
FORTUNATELY ADOPT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH TO DELIVERING
EDUCATION AND SCHOOL SERVICES
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
CORRECTLY MOVED MORE AND MORE
DECISIONS AWAY FROM SACRAMENTO.
AND HAVE SOUGHT TO EMPOWER
LOCAL SCHOOLS WE CANNOT IGNORE
THE REALITY THAT WE HAVE OVER
NINE HUNDRED DISTINCT
INDEPENDENT SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ALL WITH THEIR OWN UNIQUE
STRUGGLES AND OPPORTUNITIES
HOLDING. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION OVERLOOKS THE REALITY
THAT THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS VERY ACROSS OUR
DIVERSE STATE. THIS BILL ALSO
SPENDS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
NEW AND EXPANDED CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS WITH ADDITIONAL
ONEROUS REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL
BOG DOWN SCHOOL DISTRICTS UNDER
MORE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
PRIORITIZE COMPLIANCE. OVER
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS BASED
ON LOCAL NEEDS THE SOLUTION
DOES NOT LIE IN UNIFORMITY AND
STANDARDIZATION. THE SOLUTION
LIES WITH OUR LOCAL SCHOL
DISTRICTS TEACHERS FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WHO KNOW THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AND HOW BEST TO MEET THEM
WE MUST ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO INNOVATE AND ADAPT. AND USE
THEIR KNOWLEDGE TO ADDRESS THE
BEST NEEDS OF THEIR LOCAL
STUDENTS. NO TOOLS NO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE THE SAME JUST
LIKE NO TWO CHILDREN ARE LIKE.
SCHOOLS IN KERN COUNTY ARE NOT
THE SAME AS SCHOOLS IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE CANNOT TREAT
THEM THE SAME. SCHOOL CHOICE
FREEDOMS. HAVE BEEN SHIPPED
AWAY FOR YEARS AND THIS BILL IS
NOTHING SHORT OF AN AGGRESSIVE
TARGETING OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
ESPECIALLY NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS IN INDEPENDENCE DAY
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDED
IMMEDIATE QUALITY EDUCATION
WELL STUDENTS AND PARENTS WERE
PERSEVERING. THROUGH DISTANCE
LEARNING. OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TEACHERS PARENTS AND
STUDENTS HAVE PERSEVERED INDEED
THE TRYING TIMES MUCH HAS BEEN
ASKED OF OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. SACRAMENTO SHOULD NOT
BE TAKING MORE POWER BUT SHOULD
BE EMPOWERING OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM THE
SOLUTIONS ARE LOCAL DISTRICTS
AND FAMILIES HELPED US FIND TO
ADAPT FOR FROM A JUST
CONSTANTLY CHANGING EDUCATIONAL
VARMINT. BUT TO MOVE BACK TO AN
OLD INEFFECTIVE TOP DOWN SYSTEM
MISSES THE MARK I AM
FORTUNATELY URGE ANOTHER. MS
CREEK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I STAND AND RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRTY OUR
BUDGET AT TRAILER BILL FOR
EDUCATION. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SHOWS A HUGE INVESTMENT INTO
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND AREAS OF
EDUCATION THAT HAVE LACKED
FUNDING IN THE PAST. THIS BILL
FUNDS UNIVERSAL T. K. WHICH WE
KNOW HAS BEEN AN AREA THAT WHEN
OUR YOUNG CHILDREN START EARLY
WITH EDUCATION THEY HAVE MUCH
MUCH MORE CHANCES OF SUCCESS IN
THE FUTURE. IT FUNDS DUAL
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS WHICH WE KNOW
THAT WHEN CHILDREN SPEAK MORE-THAN ONE LANGUAGE THEY HAVE
MANY MANY OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
YOUNGER THAT THEY LEARN A
SECOND LANGUAGE THE BETTER
SUCCESS THEY HAVE. THIS BILL
INVEST IN MENTAL HEALTH FOR OUR
STUDENTS AS WE KNOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN A DRAMATIC YEAR FOR
PARENTS TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
WE KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS NEED
THAT SUPPORT. IT SUPPORTS
FOSTER CHILDREN. AND AS WAS
MENTIONED IT'S SUPPORT
INVESTING AND LUNCHES STUDENTS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO TO SCHOOL
WORRIED THAT THEY WILL BE
EMBARRASSED AS THEY GO INTO THE
LINE. TO PURCHASE A SCHOOL
LUNCH AND THEN BEING SENT OUT
TO ANOTHER LINE WITH A BROWN
BAG LUNCH THAT SAYS YOU DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR LUNCH SO
THEREFORE WE'LL GIVE YOU THIS
PAPER BAG WITH AN APPLE IN IT.
THING THAT ALL TOO MANY TIMES.
IN ADDITION THIS BUDGET FOCUSES
ON AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WE
KNOW THOSE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS OR WHERE WE SAVE KIDS
WE SAVE KIDS FROM GOING HOME.
TO FAMILIES THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE
CHILD CARE THEY'RE BUSY THEY'RE
DOING THEIR HOMEWORK AND THAT'S
WHERE WE WANT THEM. SIX A GOOD
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT AB ONE
THIRTY. AMOS QUICK SILVA
MISRATA THERE'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO
SEE THAT A LOT OF WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND SUB TO AND I
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR HAS
MADE IT INTO THE BUDGET WE
FOUGHT SO HARD TO GET INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
FOR THE UNIVERSAL T. K.
EXPANSION AND FOR THE STATE TO
RESPONSIBLY ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
PAY BACK T. K. THROUGH TWELVE
DEFERRALS. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY S THAT MOVING FORWARD WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT EDUCATION
FUNDING WORKS FOR EVERYONE WE
SHOULD WORK TOWARDS ALLOCATING
FUTURE INCREASES AND PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS. TO MORE
FULLY SUPPORT OUR BASE FUNDING
THROUGHOUT THE FF YES A 5%
INCREASE IN BASE FUNDING IS
GREAT. BUT WE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT WHILE EXPANDING
CATEGORICAL GRANTS IS HELPFUL
TO SOME. IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
BLESSING THAT IT SEEMS. THE
GROWTH IN CATEGORICAL FUNDING
SHIFT CONTROL AWAY FROM OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THIS
IS NOT WHAT THEY NEED THEY NEED
FLEXIBILITY. WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT SACRAMENTO
DOESN'T ALWAYS KNOW BEST AND
SHOULDN'T PRETEND TO. SO TODAY
I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS AND
I ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE BUT
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND GIVE OUR
LOCAL DISTRICTS MORE CONTROL
AND FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU.
THANK OF HIS FATHER'S MISTER
MATHIS. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. YOU KNOW IN LOOKING AT
THIS FOR EDUCATION. IN LOOKING
AT THE TIME THAT I'VE SPENT
WITH THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE
MAKE UP MY DISTRICT. IN TALKING
TO THEM THE BIGGEST THING THAT
I'VE LEARNED FROM THE SCHOOLS
OVER THE YEARS IS. WE NEED MORE
LOCAL CONTROL. WE NEED A FLOOR
FOR OUR SMALL DISADVANTAGED
SCHOOLS WHO SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD ALL THESE GREAT PROGRAMS.
THIS DOES NOT PROVIDE THAT FOR
THEM. THIS STILL LEAVES THEM
OUT. IT I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
THINGS HERE THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF REALLY BAD THINGS HERE. I'VE
TALKED TO MY SUPERINTENDENT I
ASK YOU WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THIS AND THEY'RE LIKE AB IS.
IT'S GOOD AND BAD WHAT I KNOW
IS WE CAN DO BETTER. WE CAN DO
BETTER THAN THROWING OUT THE
LOCAL CONTROL. THAT MANY OF US.
HAVE PUT SWEAT EQUITY IN. UP
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO TRY TO
MAKE IT BETTER WORDS GONNA
THROW THAT OUT. IT REALLY MAKES
ME QUESTION. THE TRANSPARENCY
OF THIS WE ALL KNOW WE DIDN'T
DO A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WE
DIDN'T DO THESE OTHER THINGS WE
DIDN'T MAKE IT. YOU KNOW. THE
WAY WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
THANKFULLY WE WE'VE ALL HAD A
LITTLE. BIT MORE TIME TO
ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT HAVE SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS. THE
MEMBERS I MEAN SERIOUSLY YOU.
TO THROW OUT THE LOCAL CONTROL
FORMULA THAT WE'VE ALL WORKED
ON. SOME OF Y'ALL NINE YEARS
SOME OF US SEVEN YEARS. SOME OF
US ALITTLE BIT LESS BUT TO
THROW THAT AWAY. NOW AFTER THE
PANDEMIC AFTER WE KNOW THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEGGING US. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
CORRECT WITH OVER NINE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM WORKS
DIFFERENTLY. THEIR POPULATIONS
ARE DIFFERENT THEIR CHALLENGES
ARE DIFFERENT. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE AWAY. THE ONE TOOL THAT IS
NECESSARY. TO HELP THEM ADDRESS
THEIR LOCAL POPULATIONS MEMBERS
WE CAN DO BETTER. I ENCOURAGE
YOU ALL. TO DO THAT I'M NOT
VOTING ON THIS AND NEITHER
SHOULD YOU. MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. YEAH THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AND I
DO WANT TO SIDE START BY SAYING
I THINK THERE WAS SOME SOME
VERY INCREDIBLE BIPARTISAN WORK
DONE THIS YEAR IN THE EDUCATION
BUDGET SUB- AND I GIVE CREDIT
TO THE CHAIRMAN. OF THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE WORK THROUGH
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES AND I
THINK THERE IS. YOU KNOW AS HAS
BEEN SAID I THINK THERE'S SOME
VERY POSITIVE THINGS- THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED THROUGH THAT
WORK- I WISH THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE REALLY PUSH
FORWARD OF ONE OUT. IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR.
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT TO
POINT TO IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASES TO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THE INCREASE IN AND ENSURING
THAT THERE WOULD BE A COLA
INCREASE FOR C. T. VITAL CTE
PROGRAMS THAT WE NEED. IN OUR
SCHOOLS THERE ARE THINGS I
THINK WE CAN POINT TO A RECORD.
EDUCATION FUNDING BUDGET.
GETTING FUNDING OTHERS
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN AND
ESPECIALLY WITH EVERYTHING THAT
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN THROUGH
IN THIS PAST YEAR ALL POSITIVE
THINGS BUT UNFORTUNATELY I
CANNOT SUPPORT. THIS TRAILER
BILL IN THIS ULTIMATE DEAL
TODAY AND I WANT TO OUTLINE WHY.
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT. NUMBER ONE THIS BILL
UNFAIRLY DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
CHARTER SCHOOLS. THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY REQUIREMENTS
THOUGH I THINK ARE A GOOD TOOL
TO ENSURE THAT OUR TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS DON'T PLAY GAMES.
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO DID SEVER
CISCO UNIFIED DID AND NOT
OPENING AND HAVING IT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO APPLY TO USE A
BACK DOOR TO SOMEHOW USE
INDEPENDENT STUDY TO GET AT.
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS
WHO ACTUALLY WERE THE SAVING
GRACE. FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND
ACTUALLY PERFORMED VERY WELL
AND HELP ENSURE THAT KIDS WERE
GETTING AN ADEQUATE EDUCATION
AT A TIME WHEN THEY COULD NOT
BE. IN PERSON. WE ACTUALLY
GROWTH IN PEOPLE GOING TO NON
CLASSROOM BAY CHARTERS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. THE CONTINUE
MORATORIUM ON NOT ALLOWING ANY
MORE NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS IS UNFAIR AND IT
SHOULD BE PART OF THIS DEAL. IN
ADDITION TO IT SHUTS DOWN
FUNDING FOR ANY CHARTER SCHOOLS
FOR THE NEW EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. OUR NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THAT. THIS IS
A AND KEEP IN MIND THIS IS A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM NOW THAT
WE'RE CREATING THIS SUPPOSED TO
BE FOR OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES BUT
WE'RE GOING TO SAY THAT NON
CLASSROOM THAT CHARTERS. CAN'T
HAVE THAT. THAT'S WRONG. IT'S
WRONG TO BE IN THIS TRAILER
BILL. AT THE LAST MINUTE TO PUT
THESE THINGS IN HERE. THE OTHER
THING IS CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING INSTEAD OF HAVING
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR ALL
DISTRICTS IS WRONG THE GOVERNOR
IS THE ONE WHO PUSH THAT BY THE
WAY THE GOVERNOR SAID MONEY
SHOULD GO TO CONCENTRATION.
GRANTS FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT MEANS THAT ONLY CERTAIN
SCHOOLS WILL GET THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AND THAT
MEANS THAT LOW INCOME. ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND FOSTER
KIDS IN OTHER SCHOOLS WON'T GET
THAT INCREASE FUNDING AND THAT
IS WRONG. AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE PUSHED BACK AGAINST
THE GOVERNOR AND SAID NO WE'RE
DOING SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
ACROSS THE BOARD TO HELP ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN ALL KIDS.
I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED WITH
RECORD FUNDING THEY WERE
PUTTING OUT THERE THERE IS A
VERY DANGEROUS LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN THIS BILL
AND I'LL POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS. THE DASHBOARD IS ONCE
AGAIN SUSPENDED. YEAH I KNOW
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BUDGET-COMMITTEE AGREES WITH ME ON
THIS WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
GET THAT ACCOUNTABILITY BACK WE
NEED TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FEET TO THE
FIRE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WE'RE WE'RE LOSING TWO YEARS
TWO YEARS WORTH OF DATA THAT.
COULD BE HELPFUL. AND HELPING
US TO ADDRESS LOW PERFORMING
SCHOOLS TO MAKE SURE THOSE KIDS
IN THOSE SCHOOLS ULTIMATELY.
ARE GETTING A GOOD EDUCATION
AND THERE'S TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. COMING IN TO HELP
SUPPORT SCHOOLS THAT AREN'T
MEET THAT AREN'T MAKING THE
GRADE. WE DON'T HAVE THAT IN
THIS BUDGET WE TAKE IT OUT WE
WAIVE. IN THIS BUDGET WE WAIVE
UNANNOUNCED VISITS TO LOW
PERFORMING SCHOOLS WHICH IS
WHERE THAT. THIRTY SECONDS AT A
TIME WHEN WE NEED GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURETHAT
NONE OF OUR KIDS ARE FALLING
BEHIND AND ALTERNATELY AND THIS
IS. A BIT OF A CHANGE OF HEART
FOR ME I THINK THAT THE T. K.
FOCUS. IS THE WRONG POLICY
CHOICES AND I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS A LOT THIS YEAR. BUT BY
FOCUSING THAT MONEY ON T. K.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE THE
FACILITIES. INSTEAD OF
INVESTING IN OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE OF CHILD CARE
AND EARLY EDUCATION I THINK IS
ULTIMATELY THE WRONG. POLICY
CHOICES THINK WE WILL FIND THAT
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY.
SUSTAINABLY TO HAVE THESE T. K.
PROGRAMS WE SHOULD INSTEAD
REALLY FOCUSING ON EXPANDING-
EXPANDING SLOTS IN EARLY
EDUCATION. AND CHILDCARE AND M.
AND WE DO IN THIS ENSURE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE GOING
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT THAT'S
WHERE OUR FOCUS I THINK TRULY
NEEDS TO BE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
KIDS ARE READY. WHEN THEY START
KINDERGARTEN THANK YOU. MISTER
GIBSON YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'VE CERTAINLY OF
ENJOYED THE ROBUST CONVERSATION
HERE TODAY BUT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
ONE THIRTY THE EDUCATIONAL
TRAILER BILL FIRST LET ME
COMMEND THE- THE BUDGET CHAIR
THE BUDGET SUB CHAIRS- AND
THEIR STAFF ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
RIGHT INVESTMENTS ARE MADE FOR
THE BETTERMENT OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE TEACHERS ACROSS OUR COUNTRY
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES. SOME OF
THE OTHER CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
I LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM THIS
SOMETHING I CHAMPION OF FOR
MANY MANY YEARS IN THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL
REIMAGINE PUBLIC EDUCATION WITH
SERVICES TO ADDRESS STUDENTS-
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL LEARNING- AND SO MUCH
MORE ALONGSIDE THE
SUPERINTENDENT WHO WAS A MEMBER
OF THIS FLOOR A MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE WE CHAMPION THIS TOGETHER
THE EFFORTS TO PUSH COMMUNITY
SCHOOL MODEL. FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND I AM EXCITED TO SEE
THAT THIS TYPE OF INVESTMENT
MOVES FORWARD THIS BILL ALSO
INVEST THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP
EDUCATE I'M EDUCATION AGENCIES
IMPROVE ACCESS TO RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND RETAIN A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE THIS REFLECTS MY BILL
AB FIVE TWENTY WHICH SEEKS TO
EXPAND DIVERSIFYING THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE
FOR STUDENTS BY ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE MORE SUPPORTED AND A
STRONG PIPELINE GET THIS A
STRONG PIPELINE TO PROMOTE.
MALE TEACHERS OF COLOR IN
EDUCATION ALSO IT HAS A NEXUS
WITH AB FIVE TWENTY THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL ALSO PROVIDES ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS EDUCATORS AFFECT OF
THIS OF BLOCK GRANTS TO
EXPEDITE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS AND
STAFF. ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT I
AM A STEWARD FOR CHANGE. AND I
AM PROUD THAT WE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THE RIGHT
DIRECTION EXPRESSLY AFTER A
VERY VERY VERY TOUGH YEAR THAT
WE ALL FACE AND GOING THROUGH
EQUITY NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO BE
A GUIDING- CENTERPIECE FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN THIS
HOUSE LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN AND
FOR THOSE ARE IN THE BACK SO
THEY CAN HEAR ME CLEARLY. I
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE LENS TO BETTER
COMMUNITIES THAT FOR FAR TOO
LONG HAVE ONLY J. HAVE ONLY
JUST NEEDED A FAIR SHOT AND A
SEAT AT THE TABLE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SEPT SHARES I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS THE
RIGHT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION NOW RESPECTFULLY ASK
A STRONG AYE VOTE. ALL AB ONE
THIRTY. THANK IMAGE CAPTION MR
MURATSUCHI. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE AS A
PARENT AS A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND AS A FORMER CHAIR OF
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO. TO SAY THAT. WE
HAVE AS A OUR BUDGET SHERMAN
SAID. MANY TIMES WE HAVE COME
SUCH OF A LONG WAYS. IN THIS
BUDGET THIS HAS SO MANY GREAT
THINGS IN THE BUDGET YOU KNOW
FROM THE 5% COLA. PAYING OFF
ALL DEFERRALS INSTANT RELIEF.
SPECIAL EDUCATION INCREASING
AND FUNDING INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I
MEAN THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS THIS. THIS BILL. BUT I.
ALSO AS A FORMER CHAIR BUDGET
SUB TO I WANT TO. ACTUALLY
HIGHLIGHT THE AGREEMENT WITH SO
MY COLLEAGUES. CROSS THE AISLE
MY COLLEAGUES FROM SANTA
CLARITA. AND FROM NICOLAS.
WHILE WE TALK ABOUT THE
INCREASES AND PER PUPIL FUNDING
THAT THIS BUDGET PROVIDES. WE
ARE INCREASINGLY SEEING. AND
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS A TALE OF
TWO CITIES DISTRICTS THAT
NEIGHBOR EACH OTHER ONE THAT IS
A CONCENTRATION. GRANT ELIGIBLE
DISTRICT AND ONE IS NOT. CASE
IN POINT IN MY DISTRICT. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED IN TORRANCE
UNIFIED. NEIGHBOR RIGHT NEXT TO
EACH OTHER THERE'S ONLY ONE
ROAD THAT SEPARATES LA UNIFIED
FROM TORRANCE UNIFIED WESTERN
AT WESTERN AVENUE. THE BIG
STREET AND LOS ANGELES TO ST
THAT'S FAMILIAR TO MANY OF US
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
TORRANCE UNIFIED HAS ALMOST 40%
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER STUDENTS
FOSTER KIDS. AND YET TORRANCE
UNIFIED GETS 40% LESS AND ABA
FUNDING THE NEIGHBORING LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED. YOU KNOW. I AM
WAITING. JUST SAYS BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO WHEN THERE
WERE FAMILIES THAT CHALLENGED.
THE INEVITABLE STATE FUNDING
SYSTEM THROUGH A SERIES OF
LAWSUITS THE SERRANO VERSUS
PRIEST LAWSUITS. THAT
INVALIDATED THE STATE FUNDING
BASED ON A DENIAL OF EQUAL
PROTECTION OF EQUAL. OF EQUAL
TREATMENT I AM WAITING TO SEE
IF SOMEONE SOMEWHERE IN THE
STATE RISES UP TO CHALLENGE
THOSE GROWING INEQUITIES I KNOW
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WE TRY. TO
WE PUT WE PROPOSE WE PASSED THE
COMPROMISE THE LEGISLATIVE.
BUDGET HAD THE DOLLARS TO
FOLLOW THE DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS WITH. THE SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANTS BUT THIS ABBASI'S ON THE
CONCENTRATION GRANTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR INSISTED INSISTED UPON
AS A STEP AWAY FROM YOU CAN
PROTECTION FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AND SO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON. THE
INADEQUACY OF THE BASE GRANT
YOU KNOW THE BREAD AND BUTTER
FUNDING THAT GOES TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE. THAT WE CAN PROVIDE AN
ADEQUATE. FUNDING I MEAN THIS
THIS BUDGET BECAUSE IT HAS SO
MUCH MONEY ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
EVERYONE IT MASKS A LOT OF
THESE. OF THESE PROBLEMS BUT
BUT WE NEED TO ADDRESS. THE
GROWING INEQUITY IN TERMS OF
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WELL WITH ALL OF YOU TO
ADDRESS THIS ONGOING ISSUE.
AMOS MURATSUCHI MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. FOR FIFTEEN
MONTHS CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN FOR NO GOOD
REASON WE'VE BEEN FORTY NINTH
OR FIFTIETH IN THE COUNTRY IN
GETTING KIDS BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM AND IS THIS RESULTED
IN SOME GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS IN
DISEASE CONTROL NOW WE'VE DONE
AS BAD OR POORLY AS STATES
WHERE KIDS HAVE BEEN IN SCHOOL.
FULL TIME. SO YOU THINK WE'LL
BE DOING EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO MAKE SURE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. BUT INSTEAD THIS
BILL EXPLICITLY CONTEMPLATES. A
PERMANENT POLICY OF NON DATA
BASED SHUTDOWNS. BUT EVEN
BEFORE THE SHUTDOWN.
CALIFORNIA'S UNDER PERFORMANCE
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION WAS STAGGERING WE HAD
SOME OF THE NATION'S LARGEST
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS WE RANK FORTY
NINE. AT A FIFTY IN EDUCATION
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S EASY TO BECOME
DESENSITIZED TO THESE NUMBERS
BECAUSE WE'RE LAST IN SO MANY
THINGS BUT THAT'S MILLIONSOF
KIDS WHO ARE NOT GETTING THE
EDUCATION THEY NEED SOME OF
THEM EVEN SUED THE STATE
SUCCESSFULLY. BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT BEING TAUGHT THREE. SO WHAT
DOES THIS BILL O WELL IT
PROVIDES FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS MORE IN FUNDING. AND
THAT MAY COME AS GOOD NEWS TO
SOME BUT THERE'S NO REASON TO
BELIEVE IT'S GOOD NEWS. FOR
CALIFORNIA KIDS. ARE EDUCATION
SPENDING HAS INCREASED BY SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
DECADE WITH NO DEMONSTRABLE
IMPACT. ON STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
SO IF THE LAST SIXTY BILLION
DIDN'T HELP. WHILE THE NEXT
FOURTEEN BILLION. IN FACT THIS
BILL REINFORCES. A FAILING
MODEL IT DIED REINFORCES A
MODEL WHERE KIDS ARE ASSIGNED
TO ONE SCHOOL AND THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO GO TO THAT SCHOOL
WHAT ARE THEY LIKE IT OR NOT
WHETHER IT'S A GOOD SCHOOL OR
NOT WHETHER IT'S OPEN OR NOT
AND THEN DISTRICTS ARE JUDGED
BASED UPON THEIR COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE MANDATES RATHER THAN
THEIR RECORD. OF STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT. WE CAN DO SO MUCH
GOOD FOR SO MANY KIDS WITH SOME
COMMONSENSE REFORMS IT'S NOT
BRAIN SURGERY LET'S LOOK AT
WHAT WAS HAS WORKED IN OTHER
STATES. TO HELP KIDS LEARN TO
HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED AND LET'S
START DOING IT HERE. WE DO NOT
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PROP UP AND
REINFORCE A FAILED PUBLIC
EDUCATION MODEL WE NEED
FUNDAMENTAL EDUCATION REFORM IN
CALIFORNIA. MR MCCARTY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE KNOW THAT.
OVER HALF OF OUR STATE BUDGET
GOES TO OUR MOST IMPORTANT OUR
PRIORITY IS EDUCATING OUR YOUTH
AND OUR FUTURE FROM EARLY AT TO
COLLEGE WE KNOW THE 40% GOES TO
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM NTK
THREE TWELVE THIS IS A BUDGET
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT EDUCATORS
AND FRANKLY LAWMAKERS. HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
GENERATIONS ADEQUATELY FUNDING
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND FOCUSING
ON ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN ON OUR
WISH LIST FOR A LONG TIME
MAKING SURE WE HAVE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO PRE K. PROGRAMS FOR
ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS IN
CALIFORNIA. MAKING SURE WE HAVE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS SO KIDS
CAN LEARN AND NOT BE HUNGRY.
EVERY MEMBER HERE ALWAYS TALKS
ABOUT IMPROVING CTP PROGRAMS TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE. STUDENTS CAN
FOCUS ON CAREER AND POTENTIALLY
HIGHER EDUCATION WE DOUBLE
MONEY FOR C. T. E. THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON THE A. THREE G.
IMPROVEMENT GRANT TO HELP
STUDENTS GET READY. AND TAKE
EIGHT THIRTY COURSES THE GOING
THROUGH COLLEGE. AND YES WE DO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE GOING TO
WEEK REAL PUT OUR SCHOOLS THIS
FALL. WE GET RID OF THE POLICY
THAT HAS- SCHOOLS BE ABLE TO DO
THE DISTANCE LEARNING AND THE
AND THE BIFURCATED ZOOM SCHOOL
BECAUSE THAT WAS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER. SO WE ARE GOING BACK
TO SCHOOL WITH FULLY FUNDED.
PROGRAMS THIS FALL MAKE NO
MISTAKE. BUT I DO WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE ISSUE THAT THE THAT THAT
THIS SOMEHOW WASN'T A PROCESS
WE LOOKED INTO THE
CONSIDERATION OF ALL SCHOOLS
AND ALL DISTRICTS THIS WAS A
VERY CONSENSUS DRIVEN PROCESS
IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE PROBABLY
9098% A CONSENSUS ON OUR
ACTIONS. AND THIS NOTION THAT
WE GET AWAY FROM LOCAL CONTROL
IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WE ADOPTED THE L. C.
F. F. POLICY. THAT FOCUSES ON
GIVING MORE MONEY TO OUR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO THEY CAN
MAKE THEIR CHOICES. WE DO THAT
WE FOCUS ON THE BASIS OF
FUNDING WE ALSO REALIZE. THAT
SCHOOLS THEY GET MORE MONEY
THEY HAVE MORE PROBLEMS AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK ANY OF YOU AND YOUR
COMMUNITIES IF YOU SAY YOU WANT
MORE MONEY THAN THE SCHOOL
ACROSS THE STREET. DO YOU WANT
A SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS A LOT OF
THESE CHALLENGES THAT FOCUSES
ON OVER SOMETIMES 70% OF YOUR
STUDENTS. OTHER LOW INCOME
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS BECAUSE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EDUCATING
THESE SCHOOLS THESE COMMUNITIES
COST MORE MONEY THAT WAS. THE
CHOICE THAT WE MADE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A DECADE AGO
WE FOLLOW THIS TO THE LAW. AND
WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS WHAT
WORKS TO MAKE SURE WE CAN LIFT
EVERYBODY UP. OUT OF POVERTY
AND BRING EDUCATION LEVELS
ACROSS ACROSS THE BOARD. SO
THIS IS THE PREMISE THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING HERE FOR TEN YEARS.
THERE HAS BEEN A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN ALL FUNDING THIS
YEAR. RIGHTFULLY SO THE SCHOOLS
WITH THE MOST AMOUNT OF
CHALLENGE OF THE MOST AMOUNT TO
HELP. GET THE MOST AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT. THIS IS GOOD FOR OUR
STUDENTS A GOOD FOR A GUY
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY THANK YOU MEMBERS SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MR TANG YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS VERY. ROBUST
DEBATE ON FRANKLY PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT IF NOT
THE MOST IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT
WE TALK ABOUT. ALL YEAR. THIS
BILL AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
REALLY REFLECTS. WHAT SCHOOLS
HAVE BECOME. WE HAVE DEVASTATED
OUR SOCIAL SAFETY NETS ARE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. ALL
ACROSS THIS PARTICULAR COUNTRY
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO COME BACK
FROM ALL THOSE CUTS DURING THE
LAST GREAT RECESSION. IF SO
WHAT DOES HAPPEN TO ALL THOSE
FAMILIES BECAUSE THOSE FAMILIES
WHO NEEDED HELP. DIDN'T STOP
NEEDING HELP BECAUSE- SERVICES
GOT CUT. THEY WENT TO THE ONLY
PLACE WHERE THEY COULD GO.
WHICH WHICH QUITE OFTEN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL. THOSE
CHILDREN TURN TO SCHOOLS FOR
FOOD FAMILIES TURN TO SCHOOLS
FOR HEALTH CARE WHETHER THAT
WAS VISION OR DENTAL OR THE
SCHOOL NURSE. WE ALL KNOW THAT
IF STUDENTS AREN'T HEALTHY OR
THEY'RE NOT FED THEY CAN'T
LEARN. SO THIS BILL ETHNOLOGIST
THE HUGE ROLE THAT EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL PLAYS AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE FED
FOR STUDENTS ARE HEALTHY BUT
THE CARE FOR THAT THE WATCH FOR.
AND THIS DOESN'T MOVE ANY MONEY
AWAY FROM LOCAL CONTROL. THE
LOCAL CONTROL CONTINUES TO BE
INCLUDE THE FUNDING CONTINUES
TO BE INCREASED. BUT LET'S
REMEMBER WHAT ARE OUR DEBATE
WAS FOUR MONTHS AGO. BECAUSE
FOUR MONTHS AGO WE WEREN'T
LOBBYING LOCAL CONTROL AND IF I
WAS INVOLVED IN LOOKING CONTROL
BECAUSE LOCAL CONTROL COSTS
ALMOST ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STREET TO BE
CLOSED. I WANT TO CLOSE THIS
LOCAL CONTROL STRUGGLED WITH
BEING ABLE TO OPEN OUR SCHOOLS
EXCEPT FOR THE- FEW MINUTES FEW
MINORITY OF SCHOOLS. SO AGAIN.
THIS BILL ENSURES OUR SCHOOLS
WILL BE OPEN IN THE FALL NOT
ONLY ARE THEY GOING TO BE OPEN
INVOLVED ACTUALLY GONNA GET THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO DO SO MANY
OF THE CRITICAL SERVICES
THEY'VE ALREADY PROVIDED FOR
KIDS WITH THEIR TO EDUCATING
OUR KIDS MAKING SURE TEACHERS
AND STAFF HAVE MORE RESOURCES
WHETHER IT'S TAKING CARE KIDS
BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL WHETHER
IT'S FEEDING OUR CHILDREN WITH
THEIR TO ENSURING THAT THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES OF THOSE WHO
NEED A LITTLE MORE HELP OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION GET. THE
RESOURCES AND THE HELP THAT
THEY SORELY SORELY NEEDS THIS
IS REALLY. A LANDMARK BILL THIS
IS A BILL THAT WE SHOULD BE
PROUD OF. I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD LET THIS BILL BE
DERAILED BY ONE SPECIAL
INTERESTS. OR BECAUSE ONE
SPECIAL INTERESTS THE HAS HAS
THIS HAS AN OBJECTION ON THIS
BILL. I THINK THE BIGGEST
WINNER. ARE THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS BIGGEST WINNER OUR
CHILDREN'S IN OUR FAMILIES IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL IN AB ONE THIRTY.
THANK YOU MUCH TAKE WITHOUT
CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BOB EVER SO.
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS TEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OF FOR SO TO ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY TWO C. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL TO
PRINT A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
FOR AB ONE THIRTY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT REQUEST IS GRANTED MEMBERS
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF AMENDMENTS
ON FILE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE UP.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY SIX
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX SB THREE
NINETY ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COVERAGE WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY ONE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES MISS
DAVIS HOW THE AMENDMENTS RIGHT.
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE
AMENDMENTS TO SP THREE NINE ONE
CREATES A CONSISTENT STANDARD
FOR HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS AND
EMERGENCY MEETING PROCEDURES AS
AUTHORIZED BY THIS LEGISLATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DAVIS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE. AND
WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE S. B. FIFTY
ONE. FOR THE PURPOSE OF A MAN
AS COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO MISS CARILLO ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS SB FIFTY ONE
ADDRESSES AN URGENT CRISIS IN
EL SERENO IN MY DISTRICT. THAT
ALIGNS WITH GOVERNOR NUISANCE
AFFECT OF ACTIONS TO FOSTER
HOUSING INNOVATION ON ACCESS
STATE LAND IN AN EFFORT TO
RAPIDLY INCREASE HOUSING
OPTIONS. THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING THE
NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. DAVIS
CARILLO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOTTED THE BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE. M. AS OUT
THERE AS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE THE CENTENNIAL
BIRTHDAY OF OUR FORTIETH FIRST
LADY NANCY REAGAN- WHO LIVES IN
REST IN MY COMMUNITY AND SEAMY
VALLEY AT THE RONALD REAGAN
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY I LOOK
FORWARD TO RECOGNIZING HER.
OFFICIAL CENTENNIAL BIRTHDAY IN
MY RESOLUTION ON MONDAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS VALDERS.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR WE WILL MOVE TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE
WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THREE BY
CENTER- BURKE AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO VETERANS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
TWO BY CENTER- BURKE RELATIVES
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WEEK. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
TWO BY CENTER GONZALEZ RELATIVE
TO DISTRACTED DRIVING SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
EIGHT BY SINGLE PARENTS HAVE TO
SIGN SITE CYCLE PROGRESSES
AWARENESS MONTH. SINECURE
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY CENTER
PAN RELATIVE TO A PI DAY
AGAINST BULLYING AND HATE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY THREE BY SEVEN NEWMAN
RELATIVE TO C. A. S. A.
APPRECIATION DAY. ANSWER THE
CURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY SIX BY
CENTER- BURKE AND OTHERS CLOSER
TO CALIFORNIA TOURISM OFF-
CLICK ON THE OVER THE ROLE THAT
ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD AS CO
AUTHORS TO THE RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
ON THE RESOLUTIONS I CONSENT.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. WELL
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED WE ARE
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THEY NEVER WISH REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A CONSENT CALENDAR ASSUMING
CURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS AREA
RELATIVE TO AMELIA EARHART
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY. CIRCLE FOR
THE WRONG THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER THERE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT OF
A CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
THE VOTE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR. IS
ADOPTED. CORRECT READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY NINE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SUITABLE
TO FOURTEEN I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL THREE ONLY I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SUITABLE
FOR SEVENTY NINE I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY FOUR I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL SIX FORTY I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
BILL SEVEN ONE. I SEVENTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THREE I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SIGNIFICANT
RESOLUTION THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SEVEN
CURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY TWO I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
THREE FIVE SEVENTY THREE DOWN
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SIX. SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE BILL FOUR
FOURTEEN I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SIGNIFICANT RESOLUTION
SEVEN I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO
SINCE HER RESOLUTION TWELVE I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SEVEN
FIRMS VERSION FOURTEEN I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SIX HER
RESOLUTION FIFTEEN I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY FOUR I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO INCIDENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX I SEVENTY
THREE. NO ZERO WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. OFF OF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. WHERE IN
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS.
I'M ASKING THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF WHOLE SET
THE MUST MAKE KIA A RANK AND
FILE MEMBER OF SEIU U. S. W. W.
THE UNION UNITED SERVICE
SERVICE WORKERS LAST A LEADER
ON THE PERSONNEL. AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE THAT ENSURE THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF JANITORS
AND SECURITY OFFERS. IN A
SALVADORAN IMMIGRANT WHO FOUGHT
TO RESTORE THE AMERICAN DREAM
AND MADE OUR STATE MORE GOLDEN
BY DEVOTING HIS LIFE TO ENSURE
WE HOLD TRUE. THE PROMISE OF A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. NOT A
CALIFORNIA FOR SOME. AMASSED
SERVED ON S. C. R. U. U. S. W.
W.'S EXECUTIVE BOARD ALONGSIDE
FORMER PRESIDENT MIKE OR SIERRA
AND CURRENT PRESIDENT DAVID
WENT THAT. HE HELPED CONFRONT
EVERY STRUGGLING PLAYED A
CRITICAL ROLE AS A LEADER IN
EVERY VICTORY THAT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JANITORS SECURITY AT.
WORKERS AN HOURLY WAGE WORKERS
HAVE ACHIEVED OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE MASSES THE MATH INDOOR
HARDSHIPS BUT HE ALWAYS
OVERCAME THEM BY HELPING TO
LIFT UP OTHERS HE CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM I THOUGHT I
THOUGHT. AND FOUND A JOB AS A
JANITOR AT TOYOTA. COROLLA
TOYOTA HE ORGANIZED WITH OTHER
NON UNION WORKERS ORGANIZED
STRIKES AND ONE RECOGNITION FOR
THE UNION. THIS ACTION ENSURE
THAT EMPLOYEES THAT THE
EMPLOYERS WHO WERE AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE SET UP A
MASTER CONTRACT FOR L. A.
COUNTY WHICH FOREVER CHANGED.
THE POWER OF THE NEWLY FORMED
UNION WORKERS REPRESENTING
ELLIE JANITORS AND SECURITY
WORKERS. LAMONT MUST SERVE AT
THE PEER TO PEER ADVOCATE AT A
C. A. U. U. S. W. WCSH HE WAS A
TRUE COMPOSITE AN ALLY WHO PUT
EVERYTHING ON THE LINE IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST PATRIARCHY.
SEXUAL VIOLENCE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND THE DANGERS THAT
IMMIGRANT WORKERS FACE ON THE
NIGHT SHIFT AS JANITORS MOST OF
WHOM. ARE WOMEN. A MUST JOINS
IN HEAVEN FORMER S. C. A. U. U.
S. W. W. PRESIDENT MIKE GARCIA
WHO TAUGHT HIM. AND HE TAUGHT
ME IN TWENTY ELEVEN. THAT OUR
ROLE WAS TO AMPLIFY THE VOICE
OF WORKERS. A LESSON I CARRY
WITH ME IN THIS CAPITAL THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. MY CALL THE
METHOD BEFORE THE LITTLE
SOMEONE. WHO ALWAYS WAS READY
TO GO AND READY TO GET INTO
GOOD AND NECESSARY TROUBLE. IN
HIS FINAL HOURS. THE MOST
PROTECTED VULNERABLE TENANTS
FROM AN ARMED AND VIOLENT
ATTACKER WHO SOUGHT ACCESS TO
THE MASTER KEYS. HE WAS
ENTRUSTED WITH. THIS ACT OF
BRAVERY AND SELFLESSNESS. WAS
JUST ONE OF MANY SUCH ACTS THAT
MARK THOMAS'S LIFE. HE ALWAYS
PUT THE NEEDS OF OTHERS BEFORE
HIS OWN. HE DIED A HERO. ON
JUNE SIXTEENTH. THE MASSIVE
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE
DOOR MOLINA. AND HIS THREE
CHILDREN JENNY. HE SIGHED AND
CARLA AND IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO
SHARE A FEW WORDS IN SPANISH.
WHO SET THE MUST MAKE HE I
THOUGHT THOUGH THE PERSON
FAMILIAR LOS MEMBROS THE SEIU
U. S. W. W. THAT I HOPE BUT I
MEANT WHAT I LET ME THAT THIS
WAS THAT IS KßT THOSE
COMBINED YOU DON'T THAT THAT OF
A WHOLE. YOU CAN GET PERSONA
CAN ASSESS THE VALUE THAT. SAYS
THAT THE PEOPLE SAID THAT COULD
BE GOING TO CHOP WOOD AND METAL%
MALE PARTY INFO THE LAWS THE
MASS. SO WE THAT THAT ARTICLE
THAT ABOUT A SIMPLER CAMANO THE
CITY SO COME ON THE PATIO IT
ONLY SMALL. AMOUNTS I WOULD I
THINK WENT ON THE FELLOW
CONSULATE WEAPONS SO NICELY BUT
IT DIDN'T IT. THIS YEAR YOU U.
S. W. W. MY- CAN ANY OF YOUR-
UP ALL THE- BE SOLELY. OKAY
IMPRESSED SEVEN OPEN I LOOKED
AND I LOSE AVAILABLE STEVE YEAR
WHAT WE YOUR CEMENT THAT'S UP
THE MATTER ACCORDED OTHER FORCE
WILL DOWN SOMEBODY STEPS YOU
SALUTE I SENSE WHEN YOU MANY OF.
WHEN ON THE GROUND. GET THE FOR
ME LEVELS THESE OF SEATTLE IF
YO I THOUGHT I'D LOST THE LAST
THE LAWS MATHIS I THINK THAT'LL
YEAH YOU DON'T SEE A LOT BUT
THE MUST MAKE YA KNOW BECAUSE
THAT'LL. BE THAT'LL WORK IN THE
THEATER. THE BUT TO THE LEFT
AND THAT THAT. OTHER COLOR.
LESS BOND THAT LIMON IMPROVE
THE BEST. FROM THAT THEM. FIRST
BOTH. MOLINA TO SEE ACOSTA. I
FAIL GONDOLA. IS A FROM
ELECTION THE THAT. THE MAKE
HERE. BUT I. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
MASS MEDIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MYSTERY OF MR JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY
SEIU. BROTHER JOSE TOMAS MEJIAS
A WORKING CLASS FAMILY MAN WHO
SACRIFICE EVERYTHING TO BE THE
S. CI U. U. S. W. W. LEADER HE
WAS KNOWN TO BE. FROM THE ONSET
OF HIS LIFE TOMASZ WAS NO
STRANGER TO PERSEVERANCE. AT
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN HE FLED HIS
HOMETOWN IN EL SALVADOR TO
AVOID BEING FORCED INTO THE
MILITARY DURING THE CIVIL WAR.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN HE LEFT
THE COUNTRY. TO MAY CO WHERE HE
WORKED UNTIL HE SAVED ENOUGH TO
EMIGRATE TO THE US. DURING THIS
TIME TOMASZ WAS UNABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HIS FAMILY. IT
WAS NOT UNTIL HE REACHED LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
THAT HE COULD FINALLY RIGHT TO
HIS MOTHER. TO LET HER KNOW HE
WAS ALIVE. SHORTLY AFTER
ARRIVING IN LOS ANGELES AREA HE
RECEIVED A JOB AS A JANITOR.
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS TOMASZ
NOT ONLY SERVED AS A UNION
MEMBER FOR SEIU. W. W. BUT ALSO
LATER SERVED AS AN EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER WE WAS A LEADER OF
STRONG MORAL CHARACTER. HE
TRULY DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
PROTECTING WORKING PEOPLE. HE
FOUGHT AGAINST PATRIARCHY.
SEXUAL AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THE DANGERS OF IMMIGRANT
WORKERS FACE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT
JUNE SIXTEENTH TOMASZ ONCE
AGAIN PROVED TO BE A PROTECTOR
OF OTHERS. AS THE AIM TO ENSURE
RESIDENT OF THE APARTMENT
COMPLEX HE WORKED AT. REMAIN
SAFE. UNFORTUNATELY THE MAS'S
LIFERS. TAKEN TOO SOON AND HE
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
FIFTY. TOMASZ IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE THEIR CHILDREN HIS
SIBLINGS AND HIS MOTHER. LET US
ALL REMEMBER TOMASZ THIS
HAPPINESS SHONE THROUGH HIS
SMILE HE ALWAYS SAID AND LET US
HONORED THIS SELFLESS HEROES
LIFE BY HOLDING HIS DEDICATION.
TO PROTECTING OTHERS
RECOGNIZING OUR MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURING ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
VALUED. MISTER SPEAKER. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JOSE TOMAS
ME HERE THANK. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER MISTER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR. ADJOURNING
RESINS BODY TO JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY OF THE MAS MY HERE'S-
HERE'S THE MANY OF YOU KNOW I
WORK FOR- STATE WATER DIRECTOR
FOR JOBS FOR JANITORS- WHERE AT
THAT TIME. PRESIDENT OF MY
GARCIA WAS A PRESIDENT A LOCAL
OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY BE IN THE SAME
ATMOSPHERE IN THE SAME TIME I'M
SPACE THAT TOMAS WAS THERE- I
WANT TO JUST TO SHOW MY LET NOT
THAT THE FAMILY KNOW THAT MY
PRAYERS ARE WITH- THIS FAMILY-
NOT ONLY WITH. HIS FAMILY BUT
ALSO ALL THAT ALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO KNEW AND LOVED
HIM CERTAINLY- MY HEART FRIENDS
WHEN I HEARD THE- THE SAD NEWS
THAT HE WAS BODILY KILL BUT BY
PROTECTING- OTHERS IN HIS DUTY.
AND CERTAINLY THIS IS A
TESTAMENT THAT WE'RE LIVING IN
PERILOUS TIMES- BUT I WHAT THE
FAMILY KNOW THAT WITH THIS BODY
I RECOGNIZE THE GREAT
LEADERSHIP THAT- TOMASZ
PROVIDED DAY IN AND DAY OUT
FIGHTING FOR WORKERS- IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HIS MEMORY WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
PRAY AND KEEP OUT THE MOSQUE-
IN OUR PRAYERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK MISS GIPSON. MAYES
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MR
STANLEY EUGENE WHITE A FAMILY
FRIEND AND THE SON OF MY LONG
TIME MENTOR MISTER JACK WHITE
AND EDNA WHITE. STEIN GREW UP
INVOLVED IN PARK IN MY DISTRICT
AND PLAYED BASEBALL IN THE EAST
SIDE LITTLE LEAGUE INVOLVED IN
PARK HE ALSO PARTICIPATED IN
JUNIOR ALL AMERICAN FOOTBALL.
HIS DAD JACK WHITE WAS HIS
COACH AND EVENTUALLY PRESIDENT
OF BOTH OF THOSE LEAGUE
ORGANIZATIONS HE SHARED A CLOSE
LIFETIME RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS
FATHER. STAM WAS ALSO A COACH
TO HIS SON JACK IN SEVERAL
SPORTS AND A SUPPORTER OF
ACROSS THE CANYON HIGH SCHOOL
AND HIS COMMUNITY OF ANTHONY
DOES. STAND WITH A GRADUATE OF
ALDEN PARK HIGH SCHOOL AND SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY HE MADE
HIS LIFE AND SAN DIEGO AFTER
GRADUATING COLLEGE. HE WORKED
FOR YOUR CEREALS WERE HE
ADVANCE IN THE COMPANY AND
EVENTUALLY PURCHASED THREE OF
THE STARS TO CREATE SAN DIEGO
STEREO. AND WORKED UNTIL HIS
RETIREMENT HE WAS AN AVID
BOATER AND SPENT MANY SUMMERS
ENTERTAINING FRIENDS AND
TEACHING PEOPLE TO WATER SKI AT
THE COLORADO COLORADO RIVER
INCLUDING MYSELF MY SON AIDEN
AND MY DAUGHTER NADIA. MY
FATHER LOVINGLY REFER TO HIM AS
A PUPPY TIME ON THESE TRIPS. IN
SPITE OF SEVERAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FROM HIS EARLY YEARS
STAN LIVED A VERY FULL LIFE
FILLED WITH FUN AND ADVENTURES.
HE LEFT US TOO SOON BUT HE IS
FOREVER IN OUR HEARTS. TO DAY I
ASKED THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF MR STAND EUGENE WHITE
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU IS
RUBIO. A DOCTOR WHERE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN A
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
ADJOURN THE MANY AND MEMORY-
PETER FOVEON ON. P. LEFT US ON
JUNE THIRTIETH AFTER A BATTLE
WITH THYROID CANCER HE WAS ONLY
SIXTY SEVEN. HE WAS A GOOD MAN
AND I'M HONORED TO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW HIM. I
DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVANT AND A
HUGE SUPPORTER OF HIS HOME TOWN
OF HEALDSBURG HE PLAYED A HUGE
PART IN ITS THOUGHTFUL
DEVELOPMENT. HE SERVED
HONORABLY AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND THE MAYOR FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
NINETEEN NINETY SIX POSITIONS I
ALSO HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING
HEALDSBURG TEN YEARS AFTER HIM.
HIS WIFE MARION BARBIERI FOLK
YANO TOLD THE SANTA ROSA PRESS
DEMOCRAT. HE WAS LOVED BY MANY
PEOPLE. HE WAS SELFLESS AND
KIND AND HONEST. HE WAS A
LIFELONG HEALDSBURG RESIDENT IN
THE GRANDCHILD OF FIRST
GENERATION ITALIAN IMMIGRANTS
AND THAT ONLY TELLS A SMALL
PART OF THE STORY. HE WAS NOT A
COUNTY YOUNGEST EAGLE SCOUT IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND OUTSTANDING
STUDENT WHO COME UP TO COLLECT
KEPT A COLLECTION OF HIS
TROPHIES FROM SPELLING BEES AND
DEBATE COMPETITIONS TENNIS AND
CHESS TOURNAMENTS. HE WENT ON
TO GRADUATE FROM UC BERKELEY
WHERE HE STUDIED PSYCHOLOGY AND
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION. HE
LATER RECEIVED AN MBA FROM
SACRAMENTO STATE. IS A
DEDICATED FAN OF CAL'S GOLDEN
BEARS FOOTBALL TEAM. IS A
MORTGAGE BROKER BROKER BY
PROFESSION AND HONORED HIS
FAVORITE TEAM MY NAME IS
COMPANY GOLDEN BEAR FINANCIAL.
HE CONTINUED TO SERVICE
COMMUNITY AFTER LEAVING ELECTED
OFFICE MAINTAINING HIS GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT WHAT EVER WAS
DONE WAS DONE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ITS RESIDENTS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC BEGAN CO
HOSTING THE KSR RADIO SHOW THE
DRIVER STEVE JACKSON. JOINING
STEVE DURING THE AFTERNOON
HOURS JACKSON SAID PETE WAS A
TOUGH QUESTION- BUT ALWAYS WITH
CIVILITY AND PROFESSIONALISM
AND HE WAS BECAUSE I GOT TO HIT
I GOT TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE
TOUGH QUESTIONS. PETE WAS AN
ONLY CHILD BORN TO JOANNE
ANGELINA FOR PIANO IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. AND IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE MARION I WAS LUCKY TO
KNOW P. I AM HONORED TO ADJOURN
THIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESERT PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED. IN
THE JOURNAL WE DO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE DEATHS
TO BE HELD OPEN TO PROCESS
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JULY NINTH NO FOR SESSION-
CHECK IN SESSION. MONDAY JULY
TWELFTH FOUR SESSIONS AT ONE
PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WE PASS RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MR COOLEY MOVES. MISS
REAVIS SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JULY TWELFTH AT ONE PM. THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. MISTER
MS RASMUSSEN MR COOLEY SECONDS.
THAT MEASURE COOLEY MOVES MS
REYES SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JULY TWELFTH AT ONE PM WE
ARCHER.